nos services ont alors tu es toujours
dans l'actualité tu ne quitte pas
l'actualité puisque à une émission sur
france 3 qui s'appelle comment les
intervilles du rire c'est ça oui oui
exactement je compare le mans aussi un
vrai geek alors c'est quoi oh c'est
toute une histoire que je vais essayer
de de condenser c'est une émission je
fais en réaction si je puis m'exprimer
je ne sois pas du tout réactionnaire en
réaction à un concept qui était soi
disant trouvé par mon ami si on peut
dire comme ça j'arrive à qui un jour
s'est dit tiens on pourrait faire un
intervilles sur le rire quand j'ai vu ça
j'ai dit c'est quand même curieux que
moi qui ait blanchi sous le harnais
depuis maintenant une bonne trentaine
d'années avec les intervilles les
internets interglas ce désintérêt
continent et j'en passe et des meilleurs
les interviews c'est un sûr
m qui a le mieux marché c'est les
interminables files interminables
alors j'ai eu cette réaction jeudi c'est
quand même un peu vache un piqué ça
quand même alors j'ai proposé à notre
bonne chaîne iii où je travaille pas mal
où il ya beaucoup de copains et copines
de bien vouloir faire les intervilles du
rire alors actuellement il ya un vrai il
ya une vraie bagarre entre la chaîne dit
tf1 et la chaîne dite fr3 en parlant ce
producteur qui lui fait la même émission
donc sur tf1 quelques quelques jours
plus tard tu dis que toi tu avait
inventé l'idée de jouer avec les dates
de naissance aussi et quitte à piquer
aussi pour sacrée soirée c'est vrai ça
c'est tellement vrai que ça m'est arrivé
d'une manière tout à fait impromptue
inattendu un jour à un feu rouge ça fait
des années que que je suis retrouvé les
je ne sais plus que ce qu'est ce qu'on
doit dire si c'est intelligent ou con de
faire jouer les gens en ont les
concernant tous alors j'ai je cherchais
sur les plaques minéralogiques
sur les cartes d'assurance sociale sur
les cartes d'identité
et puis ça ne concernait pas tout le
monde est bien beau jour un feu rouge je
vois sur une espèce de truc limina qui
défilent dans paris de votre naissance à
votre mort vous serez assurés par
dortmund je ne suis pas hélas c'était
avec lic me suis dit mais effectivement
la seule chose dont on est propriétaire
de sa naissance à sa mort c'est sa date
de naissance voilà le truc pour faire
jouer tout le monde alors je les fais
une deux fois notamment des missions qui
s'appelait c'est aujourd'hui demain ou
toujours sur cette bonne chaîne iii
alors quand j'ai vu ça tous les ans dans
intervilles je disais j'ai prêté 10 mois
de suite
les dates de naissance à manet me
foucault mais vous permettez je reprenne
mon bien pendue bellemare la tête et les
jambes c'est une idée à toi aussi c
un petit peu une idée à moi là je suis
un peu plus en plus nuancée autant
l'autre c'est vraiment un dock comme
caractérisé autant la tête et les gens
c'est différent un jour je vais trouver
alors j'étais un
tout nouveau dans le métier et j'avais
trouvé qu'un truc était marrant c'est de
faire un muscle esprits hautmont au tour
de france on prenait le mec le gros mois
le dernier parce que les premiers ils
sont jamais d'accord pour pour se mettre
son entraîneur on prenait le dernier de
l'étape il courait pendant qu'un post
est donc c'est toi aussi alors j'ai
appelé ça le muscle esprits mais je dois
reconnaître comme jacques antoine il a
amené sa patte et puis antenne 2 août
avait piqué jeux sans frontières sinon
assez fou le nombre d'idées quant à les
lire ici le savent pas ce qu'on voit à
procès ont la peau mais as-tu là pour
nous la mère d'un dimanche et toi non
mais j'ai dimanche non mais pourtant je
suis désolé de te dire effectivement que
dans les maisons et mangeons m'a piqué
un truc qui est extraordinaire et je
devrais toucher des droits le passé le
pas
c'est les droits sur fiat lux depuis la
création des messes du dimanche moi je
sais par le podium je suis très à
trouver quand même une grande idée aussi
ces deux tiers c'est parce que quand
quand on avait donné à gérer un magasin
à boulogne quand on aime on peut le dire
quand même ans était pas un magasin
c'était une quincaillerie quincaillerie
et tu avais l'arrivée d'une étape à
boulogne mais jamie une urne devant la
porte et tu avais dit aux jambes hâlées
ceux qui trouvent les trois gagnants de
l'étape dans l'ordre ils ont droit à ce
poste et 10000 francs 50 des mises hors
ici d'achat non c'était à l'époque la
monnaie était pas la même que maintenant
je m'emmerde elle en moyenne 1 et tout
d'un coup je dirais faut que je trouve
des idées alors j'ai foutu une grande
boîte à lettres si vous amenez avant
l'arrivée de l'étape l'étroit dans
l'ordre vous touche vous prévenir dans
le magasin vingt-cinq mille balles si
vous voulez dans le désordre vrai que ça
s'emballe alors ce qui est terrible
c'est que j'avais quatre employés le
premier jour il ya 25 à 2 2e 250
troisième jour tout le quartier venaient
2540 alors mon beau frère qui était
propriétaire du magasin quand il a vu
qu'on ne faisait plus que cela trier les
cartes et on s'occupait plus du tout de
la clientèle on sait plus une thune
d'appel ni arrêter connerie c'est comme
ça que mon tiercé s est arrêté mais que
celui de monsieur k russe qui passait
devant
le magasin qui était le grand patron de
l'indycar usine la ville en magasin à
boulot on a eu plein d'idées m'enfin la
plus grande comme intervilles ça fait
quoi d'être l'auteur d'une institution
nationale
pourquoi est une institution à travers
villes en france mais le général de
gaulle en a parlé en conseil des
ministres en en faisant l'éloge d'un jeu
que même la mongolie nous envie
tu sais que l'essayer de avant de
l'abandonner n'ont pas voulu me casque
quand on sait que konrad adenauer le
chancelier allemand de l'époque avait
demandé que ce soit adaptée au niveau
international c'est devenu je sens
france y est pas et tu dis c'est pas une
situation mais c'est ça thierry ça s'est
passé à compiègne où la petite histoire
rejoint la grande et où un donneur
rencontrait souvent de gaulle et à un
moment le père de gaulle dia de noël et
dites-moi chancelier je vais je vais
vous quittez quelques buzz instant parce
que je vais arriver à une émission qui
me plaît bien et c'est d'autant plus
avantageux pour moi c'est que ce soit il
ya deux mers qui s'opposent qui sont des
mères gaulliste alors hier via steam a
dit d'ailleurs je vais vous dire cette
émission s'appelle intervilles et nous
devrions faire un intervilles entre la
france et la louve c'est comme ça qu'ils
aient dit jeux sans frontières
incroyable oui un qui a été incroyable
c'est que quand on s'est réuni le
lendemain chez le ministre de
l'information de l'époque monsieur guy
lux il a été installé tout à fait à
l'autre bout coup comme par hasard tous
les directeurs et sous-directeurs les
lieutenants des directeurs tout le monde
était là pour voir le ministre parce que
quand de gaulle disait c'est comme local
louis xiv en chine chen ses péchés très
bon d'accord je les cheveux je lance
non
et laurent baffie qui joue le set dans
la troisième voilà merci oui c'est un
bon club seville moignard être
fermé pourquoi pourquoi n'y a plus d'
intervilles pascal pussy trône oui mais
c'est tout à fait vrai on va lui
demander de te poser une question à
l'est on écoute bien à ça me fait
plaisir mais ont ils si léon zitrone 16
114 2013 pour vous en direct pour le
chergui est ce que vous me recevez je ne
l'entends pas à on me fait signe que
nous sommes de l'antenne ma question guy
vos contrat actuel avec les chaînes
françaises belges et surtout suisse
court jusqu à 2037 vers quelle activité
allez vous vous consacrez en exclusivité
je vous donne le choix camelot éleveur
de vaches est parieurs sur lévriers ou
directeurs de casting ainsi nikon valait
choisissez
alors
merci bien aussi le schmilblick
immortalisé par coluche le palmarès des
chansons la une et à vous la classe
succès fou et la roue tourne on se
souvient de la route ou ma première
mission va la regarder proton petit
téléviseur et regarde
[Musique]
madame la vielle je reviens de marseille
il ya quelques jours et la bâche de vous
dire que vous êtes devenu maintenant la
coqueluche de tout le monde si l'on peut
dire tout le monde dit j'espère que
notre petite maman marseillaise va
gagner et nous le souhaitons tous
vraiment parce que nous savons que vous
jouez pour vos trois enfants surtout
pour cette chance unique qui s'offre à
vous de gagner une petite fortune jouer
pour gagner une gac cela qui compte nous
le souhaitons vivement près vivement
bonne chance contacter madame muriel le
cuissard hier général au tourisme vous
souhaite bonne route
quand on voit ces images de me revenir
ouais tu avais pas le même nez comment
ça se fait
à
c'est que c'était à moi c'est des trucs
que j'ai remarqué mme jean c'était avant
qu'on est ici toi par contre du genre
jeunesse vers ça sera moi je ferai plus
long soit peu c'était inventons dérapage
en alfa romeo c'est samri 1 oui tu as eu
un accident et en a profité pour non je
n'ai pas profité du tout non j'ai il me
remet le nez comme il était avant alors
maintenant c'est devenu un symbole
national il ya un temps quand même coûté
déroulement non c'était drôlement
critique et moi je me souviens quand
même j'ai pris part j'ai pris beaucoup
plus de couches dans les données ont
tapé le fossoyeur de la culture
nationale la wii se poursuivre tu t'en
souviens de sa base c'est à dire que ce
qui ce qu'ils m'ont appelé le fossoyeur
c'était des journalistes de l'époque peu
ils ont tous disparus sont tous vous
soyez si j'ose dire et moi je suis je
rentre à profil faut il faut s'en
foutent carrément la critique de touche
elle m'a beaucoup touché ouais on se
serait d'ailleurs mentir qu'elle me
touche pas encore mais maintenant que je
suis plus vraiment à l'antenne ou jeu
non j'aime d'accord pour qu'elle vous
touche pas
c'était oui c'est du sourcing qui sont
habitués à tout réussir une belle fille
la crédit tu vois la plaisanterie qu'il
accepte
j'accepte la plaisanterie il faudrait
être fou pour faire des intervilles
toutes les émissions que j'ai fait n'est
pas acceptable entre et la moquerie la
moquerie que oui puisque j'ai tendance à
me moquer aussi tpr est là parce que
j'ai une surprise j'en sais bien que tu
vas me faire non c'est gentil mais vas-y
maryse n'est pas là heureusement j'ai
pour vous simone
s'il est vrai
voilà c'est tout et pour tout
ah ah
mais bon
en proclamant
sa
à remarquer que c'est tout à fait calme
quand même il fait des cadeaux et les
rangs men va appeler lire notre surface
ils veulent attirer un public je suis de
retour après un séjour dans un pays
gorgé de soleil
geboers et simon avec l'en effectivement
mais thierry ardisson le sait comme le
disait le christ roi il faut rendre à
césar ce qui est à césar alors mon cher
guy et bien je te rend une fois pour
toutes 7e
si c'est révélateur
bah oui je crois que simone à la femme
la plus extraordinaire
intouchable incontournable il vaut mieux
et sont inquiets
c'est facile vous n'allez quand même pas
d'une corpulence tels que cantat
motocyclistes fait le tour il est obligé
de s'arrêter pour refaire le plein non
je veux dire que c'est une femme
fantastique et alors par contre la
moquerie et j'adore j'aime bien mais
celle que j'ai vue par karl zéro pendant
des désastres dire que tout allait durer
moins longtemps que toi quand même et
toi et toi là ça notre barre toi
c'est wasquehal 0 c'est moi est ce que
tu peux lui pardonner
m
j'ai prouvé que c'était contre la
traiter de [ __ ] voilà cette fois qu'on
me voit il réfléchit tu sais j'ai
d'ailleurs j'ai un document
à moitié fonctionnant tous mes sauts
c'est ce qu'a essayé d'aller pêcher si
c'est non non je n'ai tu sais qu'en ce
moment les animateurs et les
journalistes ont beaucoup de problèmes
et là j 1 j'ai un document bien en béton
pour tous et en 1960 tu te souviens
c'est pas si moi tu allais à la banque
du sperme du boulevard de trèves
souvenir ça très bien sûrement fait un
don généreux et d'ailleurs mon chéri est
pas si tu es bien ce qui devait arriver
est arrivé nous voilà je t'embrasse
loiseau
et au travers de moi pour ce parti
simone a hâté dit d'accord avec mon fils
un
grand moment
d'habitude si me lâche 2
ne te remettre la journée le tour misère
j'adore sur scène extrêmement drôle je
pense que c'est pour toi tu vas lire le
scandale pédophile contaminé sept
intéressera qu
il pourrait rater de inler 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux